griffin moving on portis head fakes  nothing there now griffin for three  yes and that's the part of the game that  through the years blake griffin has  improved upon his three-point shooting  driving there  blue collar desperation portis had the  ball but the great effort  and intensity from blake griffin  and the crowd here as you said rewarding  him showing their appreciation for the  heart  and the hustle of the former all-star  missed 11  consecutive three-point attempts in the  first half  and they are an excellent three-point  shooting team here's griffin  4-3 and that lead is now  three they fled by as many as eleven  nice pass and perfect but from down  paying for blake griffin brooklyn cruz  griffin harris james on the court for  the nets  [Applause]  griffin for three yes